i have been making videos for almost
four years now it's hard to believe
i've noticed when i watch my earlier
videos i can see that my beard is not as
gray
as it is and so these last four years
have been pretty intense
for many reasons and i've been talking
about
a symbolic structure in different guises
through different examples
and uh i've had in mind the idea of
trying to condense
the vision the cosmic vision that i was
trying to
bring to you in a single image
and it took many years thinking about it
trying to figure out
how to do it finding the courage to do
it because it's a very detailed and
complicated image
and so finally i finalized the image and
so what i want to do
is i want to look at it with you guys
and uh
talk about its meaning i won't be able
to be exhausted because
there's a lot in there but i will be
able to hint at the different aspects
show to you what it references in terms
of meaning but also
what the where it comes from where the
different images i use come from
in the tradition with either in
scripture in the iconographic tradition
or also in different legends and and
other
so we'll look at it try to get through
as much as i can and hopefully
this will be a kind of synthesis of the
cosmic vision that i'm trying to uh
trying to portray for you guys
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so of course this image is available for
those who want it you can
you can find on my social media a a
pretty good version you can download use
on your computer some people are using
it as their their
phone background but if you want to also
purchase the image there's possibility
of purchasing prints
and also have it printed on different
things i will put the links to that of
course
in the description and so here we go
looking at the image
so of course the base when you look at
the basic image
you see a mountain that is also an
island and it's surrounded by a wall
of course this mountain is the mountain
of paradise
but at the same time it's also golgotha
mountain it's also the mountain on which
christ was crucified we'll get to that
a bit later the basic idea is that it's
the mountain of paradise and it's
surrounded by a wall
paradise means an enclosed garden so
senate from the syrian talks about how
when adam and eve were chased from the
garden
god put a limit a wall around the garden
when you look at it you have to
understand it also not only as the guard
the wall of the garden but also the wall
of the church the wall of the temple
and ultimately as an image of the new
jerusalem itself
because this image is not it tries to
encapsulate everything and so you can
understand this image
as a an image of the garden of eden but
you can also understand it as an image
of the new jerusalem
which has walls around it and and doors
and in which is the tree of life and the
water of life as well
so if we look at it as the the
garden we can understand that's why we
see in the center we see
adam and eve in that central space
with the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil
and so the way that i try to portray it
in general is
this movement of unity at the top into a
kind of multiplicity
at the bottom and so we have the tree
of life which is also the cross
at the top being split into two with the
tree of knowledge of good and evil
and that split becomes bigger as we see
the fig tree which is used to cover adam
and eve
and then at the outside of the walls of
the garden we also
have the thorns which are the ultimate
separation you can imagine
that thorns have all these spiky things
on the outside to protect
people from uh from danger to protect
the garden from
the outside so we tend to think of
in scripture it says that the tree of
the knowledge of good evil was in the
middle of the garden
and saint francis has a really good way
of interpreting it
it's it's also good to understand it as
the middle in the sense of the center
but he understands it's in the middle in
the sense of the garden as a mountain
and the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil in between in the middle
between the bottom of the mountain and
the top that is
giving access both to that which is
above
but also let's say opening up the space
to
that which is below and so that's why if
you look at the way that i drew it
i separated the tree of the knowledge of
good evil into kind of two branches
which separate
one which is alive and one which
is dead this has its precedent in
medieval images for example there is an
image called the tree of life and death
in which we see the once again the image
of
a tree with eve and and the mother of
god
kind of facing each other as one
representing the fall one representing
salvation
we see the cross on one side and we see
also death
on the other and so i tried to use this
it's a more western type but i tried to
kind of integrate it into
this image i've also seen some images of
the tree of the knowledge of good evil
which has two vines you know
interwoven together to kind of represent
this relationship between
the the duality of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil
on the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil i also put the
white bird and the black bird of course
the white bird on the right side
of christ and the black bird on the left
side the white bird is returning
is coming back up and the blackbird is
moving away if you look at the entire
image you'll see
there's always a relation of opposites
all all the way through where you have
on one side something
and the other on the other side it's
opposite in this case it refers of
course
to this idea of ascending and descending
the entire image is built that way if
you look there's always
something going up and something going
down you know you look at the angel for
example holding the cup
going up and then the angel pressing
down the leviathan
you'll see that all through the image
this kind of going up and going down
and the bird the white bird of course
also refers
to the bird in the story of noah in the
story of noah
noah sent out two birds the white bird
went out and ultimately came back with
life
brought back a branch to the ark and
the blackbird went away and never came
back
and there are some images in iconography
which seem to come from
some extra biblical tradition which
shows the blackbird feeding
on a dead carcass in the water and so
you have this bird of life and this bird
of death this bird which
comes back which return which comes back
up brings
life up towards the center and then you
also have
the bird which goes away you can
understand it somehow as the scapegoat
you know the goat that is that you put
the sins on and the
goat goes away this idea of coming in
and moving out of course
the sheep and the goats which are also
there in the image if you look at the
bottom
you see that structure of the sheep
drinking the water
at the bottom of the mountain and the
goats as well
um i'm kind of moving around all around
this image but
hopefully you guys will be able to
follow as we're already talking about
the sheep and the goats you can see the
sheep and the goats at the bottom
uh drinking the water of the
the mountain but saint ephram has a very
beautiful
image about the waters of paradise he
talks about how
as the waters come down the mountain and
get further and further out
they become mixed and they become less
uh they still water the world but they
become less pure you could say
and so the influence of the garden the
influence of the center
is mitigated as it gets further and
further away you know that makes sense
in terms of any form of identity any
form of thing even
a wheel physically as you get further
the spoke get longer and longer the
influence of the
the central spoke the central uh axis
will be diminished and there'll be less
power kind of
influencing the the periphery of the
wheel
and so i had the waters coming out
of the wall of the garden through
gargoyles
and so the gargoyles obviously represent
this liminal aspect
the apotropaic imagery of the gargoyles
on the side
of the of the churches but also
the griffins who protect this idea of
the protector
there's a relationship between the
gargoyle the griffin
and of course the cherub as well they
don't play exactly the same role
the cherub has a more spiritual aspect
as a guardian
but there's a relationship in terms of
this creature this kind of
mitigated mixed creature on the outside
which protects the inside but also
is bringing the water away from the
center
and so it represents the mitigation of
the waters but also the but
it's not bad right the waters are also
still good they're just let's say
further away from the center so you see
both the sheep
which are on the right side and the
goats on the left side both
drinking from the water which is outside
if you look at the basic
idea that the garden itself has flowers
on it
and it's more kind of geometric it's
more regular
the shape of it and as you move away as
you get
as you're outside of the garden then you
see that the earth is cracked and i'm
using the trope of
the desert which we find in iconography
where we show
this kind of deserted land which is
cracked and dry and so i use that
image there as well to kind of emphasize
the difference between the garden
and the outside and also to show this
notion that the outside is a place of
of a schisis the a place of of lack
so as we're on the outside of the garden
maybe we can talk about the things that
are there
and then we can slowly move back in as
i'm kind of
kind of going all around this image now
of course when we look at the image
we see we can see adam and eve in three
different places
in the well you see them really adam and
eve directly but let's say
stand-ins for adam and eve are there all
across the the two sides but
you see adam and eve of course you see
eve giving the fruit to
adam and you see the beginning of the
fall
then we see adam and eve
running down the mountain and using the
fig tree
to cover themselves i really wanted to
put the fig tree as a separate tree
because senate from the syrian really
mentions that and
i always thought it was such a beautiful
image this idea
of the relationship between the fig tree
and the curse
we see in the gospel that christ curses
the fig tree
because and sin ephraim talks about how
it's because
it's related to the fact that the fig
tree was used to cover adam and eve
and so as christ is moving towards his
crucifixion he's kind of moving
up and he is dealing with the fig tree
and
you know removing the the covering of
the fig tree and then going up
so we see adam and eve coming down in
iconography we often
have a more condensed image where we see
adam and eve at the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil
holding the fig trees in order to hide
themselves
whereas in this image i wanted to
separate the different aspects and show
the different levels
and so the the fig you see adam and eve
running down the hill with the fig tree
and then on the outside of the garden
now you see adam and eve
wearing the garments of skin they are
have taken on fully
the animal aspect if you see that
they're at the same level as the sheep
and the goats
the there's also this fleshiness which
i'm trying to to bring about where you
see the outside as this fleshiness
in terms of seeing this image as an
image of a person
which is also is also an image of a
person
and so then we see adam and eve running
away wearing the garments of skin
and under the cherubim under the cherub
which has its four faces and is holding
the flaming sword
then we see an image of death the skull
the skull of adam which is now
underground so
what it's doing is usually in images of
the crucifixion
we see at the bottom of the cross we'll
find an
image of a skull which is this idea of
the death of adam
the the the death of adam which is at
the bottom and usually what you'll see
is
the blood of christ coming down the
cross and
covering the skull and so what i wanted
to do is stretch out the entire image
and make this whole image like an image
of the crucifixion but at the same time
a cosmic image and so we see in the
place where adam and eve are chased from
the garden
you see this image of his skull as well
the skull of adam
the image of the death of man
so i put three i put three doors
on the the wall of the garden
it's mostly to emphasize its
relationship to
uh to a church or to kind of like the
older older churches and the churches
that we
find in the west as well the older
churches in rome
have three doors of course it's not just
a traditional church or an ancient
church it has three doors
but also the iconistasis in an orthodox
church also has three doors
and so you can understand the entrance
into the garden
also as the entrance into the church but
also the entrance
into the holy of holies
and those three aspect goes up all the
way to the top because
each part of the mountain
has a central aspect which would be the
trunk of the tree
either the fig tree or the tree of the
knowledge of grenieville or the tree of
life and then on each side you see the
two sides of the mother of god
and saint john or of adam and eve
ultimately i wish i would thought i
might wanted to put like
uh to have doors all around
like you see in the description of the
new jerusalem but i ended up just
just doing three which reminds us of the
of a church around the central door of
course
are two pillars which are more
emphasized as pillars
and those of course are the the pillars
of
the temple or the the pillars that we
find at the door of the temple in the
description of the temple
in the bible uh it's a
yakin and boaz which is
this image of i've talked about this in
some talks these two pillars
that you find in scripture really are
this left-handed right hand
you have this notion of the the just
or this idea of the foundation and then
boaz who is the one who married the
foreigner
and so this idea of moving out right
just like the black bird is moving out
towards the outside the goat is moving
out towards the outside you have the
pillar that is also
let's say the inner pillar and the outer
pillar in the
the in the image
so of course all of this is moving out
and outside of the main island you see
of course the waters of chaos
the primal waters which are described in
scripture are there and i try to
emphasize this kind of chaotic turning
that we find in the uh in chaos this
kind of pointless turning you could say
you know and at the edge of the image of
course
the way to you see the leviathan the
serpent
which i wanted to do it in a way that
you can imagine it kind of coming
under the whole thing right as if
it's he's almost like a u-shape which is
under the
the whole structure and so it's kind of
laying down at the bottom of the ocean
and it really is this
limit of chaos which is there and which
tends to want to
come up and ultimately we see
the relationship between heaven and
earth
let's say there's different
relationships of heaven and earth one of
them
is a relationship of holding earth down
and that is where we see that in the
angel
which is spearing the leviathan and
refers to all the traditions we find in
uh in scripture which talks about how
the leviathan
will be will be cast down the leviathan
will be destroyed in the end
and ultimately moves towards the image
of saint michael killing the dragon so
michael killing the leviathan
so this is obviously a reference to that
so as we move of course you can see the
rivers of paradise which come
i tried to hint at the fact that there
are four if you look at the bottom of
the cross you can see that there are two
more coming
towards the outside i wasn't sure how to
do it visually
sometimes you see the four rivers lined
up like this in order to show that
there's four but
i just thought it would be better to to
have the two and then suggest the two
other
ones that are moving towards the back so
as we move up
one of the things i want to point to is
of course
i tried to create echoes between the top
and the bottom
and so there's a sense in which there's
a mirror in the middle
and that which is above is reflected in
that which is below
and so for example a small example
is i wanted to show the flowers
on the mountain and so you have all
these flowers this kind of multiplicity
of glory on the earth and then if you
look above then you also have
the stars in the heavens above which are
drawn something like
flowers and those stars resemble the
stars that you usually find
on the image of the mother of god you
have stars on her forehead and on her
shoulders
so i wanted to have this kind of
reflection of this glory above and this
glory below
the stars above and the flowers below
and so you'll see several
examples of that as well of course the
ultimate example which i can already
mention right now
is that i put around the bottom of the
wall i put
the thorns which are which also act as a
kind of
knotted ornament and so if you think of
like a greek
key or if you think of something like a
uh
you know a celtic knot i wanted to kind
of suggest this idea of like a celtic
knot but
which has thorns at the bottom and so it
ends up being like a band or a border
around
the the whole garden if you read a
description of
the um of the altar in
scripture and i think even the ark of
the covenant not sure but i know for
sure
if you read the description of the altar
in scripture there is
a band in like a ornamental band which
goes around
the altar and so that is also what i
wanted to suggest this ornamental band
which is around
the altar which is around everything
really this kind of ornament on the edge
of the world
and but what i also wanted to bring
about and also its relationship to death
and i wanted to show how that is flipped
above
and you can see above christ kind of
like the highest
his highest glory is the crown of thorns
and
i've talked about this in several videos
the amazing thing about the crown of
thorns is that it joins together the
lowest
and the very highest it joins together
death
with glory in a way that i've never seen
as powerfully done as in the story of
christ
where you really do have this image of
the very result of the fall
being transformed into glory and you can
see that
on the cross there is a crown above him
in the uh the headboard
usually there we will write jesus christ
king of the jews
or sometimes in orthodox circles they
now tend to write the king of glory
and so in order to emphasize the
imagistic
version and i wanted to also show how
you have this kind of
king king aspect
which is very high but you also have a
higher aspect which is the manner in
which god
joins his kingship with his descent as a
servant the way in which
christ joins the very highest with the
very lowest and that
appears i think more most powerfully in
the image of the crown of thorns
so i already mentioned a little bit
about the angel which is pressing down
the leviathan
but if you look at it you see there's
another angel on the other side and that
angel is carrying a cup
this refers of course to many
iconographic images where we see
an angel gathering the blood of christ
into a cup usually you see the angel
next to the cross uh with the with the
blood going into the cross
now the reason why i put them opposite
to each other is of course
this relationship that i talk about of
gathering in
but also pushing away and so you can see
that here where the
the chalice is there to gather in and
the lance is there to push away there's
also
an idea of a kind of fluidity on one
side
and then also a fixing on the other
right spearing something is also fixing
it to the wall right making it
uh definite you could say um
and so there's a relationship
this is also when the great thing about
images is that you're able to
show the opposites in a more balanced
way because
there's always aspects of opposites
which are
let's say reverse from each other so
when i talk let's say about the left
hand and the right hand
there's an aspect of the left hand which
is a dissolving aspect
and there's an aspect of the right hand
which is a fixing aspect
and the same thing with the right hand
there's an aspect of the right hand
which is a dissolving aspect and an
aspect of the right hand which is a
fixing aspect
it just depends at what level sometimes
you can say right hand
right foot or left hand left foot these
are different ways to
to talk about it but you can see in an
image you can really
show the different aspects you know um
at the same time and so so this
this angel is coming to gather the blood
of christ i showed him kind of in the
process of going to gather the blood of
christ
of course as in most crucifixion images
there is an image of the sun and the
moon
and here of course i also wanted to the
sun on the right hand of christ and the
moon on the left hand of christ
the greater and the lesser of the lights
the the the source and the mirror
you could say the one the sun of course
is the source of light and the
the moon as the mirror of light
and i wanted to emphasize it in the way
that i drew it by having the sun as this
light on the inside and darkness on the
outside and the moon
as having light on the outside and
darkness on the inside
this kind of complementary relationship
which we see in the birds
and we see in different aspects of the
image
now of course standing next to the cross
is the mother of god and saint john the
apostle so now it really becomes an
image of a crucifixion
and there really is an emporia as you
reach the top of the mountain there
really is this apporia where i
tried to join the tree of life
which with the tree of death
and so the tree of life in the sense of
the cross
is really a powerful thing it's really
in a way the opposite
of the tree of good and evil if you
understand the tree of good and evil as
the tree of life and death
separated right as the separation of
life and death you could say
the tree of life in the sense of how the
cross becomes a tree of life
is a place where those two are joined
together in a way
which is paradoxical but which is also
transcendent
and so the tree of of the cross which is
the place of death
also becomes the source of life of
course
with the blood and water coming out of
christ you can see the reference and you
can see the relationship between that
blood and water coming out
and seeing the the four rivers coming
down the mountain
and watering the world it's as if those
those
those rivers are coming from the side of
christ himself
next to christ of course is the usual
image of the lance
and the uh and the sponge once again
emphasizing the two opposites the one
piercing and the water comes out
the one coming up to him and gathering
trying to gather the water into him to
feed and to
remove to to give in and to take from
and so you can see that in the image of
the lance and the
and the sponge
of course around christ i put
a kind of sun and it kind of caught in a
kind of sun which is
also let's say a
a sun which joins together you know the
the the
the more cosmic sun and the moon which
is also
a sun which has the two opposites in it
and you can see this image all around
and it's a very powerful image
every time you see that when you see a
sun represented with straight
and crooked uh glory where there is a
point but there's also a curvy point
it really is this this representation of
both the straight and the curved
you know the uh the direct and the
indirect
these two opposite joined together into
one glory
and of course in the center of the sun
is the darkness which is now the divine
darkness
and echoes the
death which you see below and so at the
bottom of the
mountain you see there's a dark space
and then there's the
the there's the skull of adam and then
at the top there's a dark space
and then in the center is the head of
christ the
the and so you see that there's this
this relationship but this transcendence
and joining both like i said life and
death
and glory and death together in one
place
which is the place of the cross so of
course next to the cross you see the
angels
often we find the angels in a position
of mourning
but here because i'm also joining the
image of the cross with the image of
this kind of cosmic center with the
image of the
temple because this wall around and this
image
this structure this tiered structure is
also the image of the church and the
image of the temple
you can imagine the wall of the temple
and then the different sections of the
temple as different veils or different
you know the outer court moving up to
the
to the to the fig tree and then
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil as the veil of the holy place
and then reaching up to the top and the
cross being the entrance into the holy
of holies
the tree of life being the last the last
entrance and so there's a three-tiered
structure the same three tiers that you
find
in the church in the temple in the
tabernacle you know the basic cosmic
three-tiered structure which you
actually find in almost every culture
but that is what is also represented on
the inside
and so usually we show the angels
mourning around the cross but what i
wanted to do
was to show the angels fanning you know
like
so that they also become like the
cherubs on the top
of the uh of the altar this idea of
you know decide this kind of glo this
fanning in the sense of this this kind
of
manifesting the spiritual aspect you can
imagine the fanning from the wings
this idea of fanning the the central
space
but we also often show them with
liturgical fans to also
remind you that this is a liturgical
image that this is
an image of the cosmos an image of
yourself an image of
of everything which i kind of joke about
but
it's also a liturgical image that is the
place at the top of the mountain
is also the altar which would have the
fans as we
as we uh as we um come to the in the
liturgy if there are liturgical fans the
fans will be held
above the uh above the uh above holy
communion
and so we're coming to the end but the
last thing maybe i want to
talk about is of course the circles
and so this was tricky because i really
wanted
to kind of show the cosmic aspect of it
and so i wanted to
have these circles in a way to show the
heavens you often see
in the um in iconography any kind of
traditional imagery
this notion of the heavens described as
these concentric circles
but i also wanted it to do it in a way
that
would hint at the same time at the days
of creation
and so if you look at the number of the
rings
you can see that there are coming from
the angel on the outside
there are one two three four five
six rings right and so those six rings
would be the six days
of creation and then then you have the
seventh day
which is represented as this kind of sun
on the inside but the best way to
understand it is mostly to understand
the sun on the inside as the first day
moving
towards the outside but there's a
strange joining of the first day
and the last day uh
in the mystery of the cross you know in
the death and resurrection of the cross
and so i wanted to leave that
kind of a dual interpretation so that
you can
understand the central sun as the first
day
but then also the the central sun as the
sabbath as well
and so you see this that's why you have
these six
rings and then the seventh which would
be the central one but then i also
wanted to separate
the central one into two so that you
have
also the eighth day which is the day of
eternity
and so the central sun is separated into
basically two rings again
and therefore you also have
the uh the the dark ness in the middle
which is
the the glory the invisible
aspect of god or the the divine darkness
and is related to this notion of the
eighth day or the day of eternity
but there's also there's also a way to
see these as the seven heavens you know
the seven
heavenly spheres of the planetary
spheres as well
that's why there there ends up being
seven
and i also wanted to leave a last
possibility which is also to represent
the circles
not as six not as seven not as eight but
even as nine um if you take the halo of
christ around his head
as the last inner circle then
then we also have the nine spheres of
heaven which are
which are represented in dante's divine
comedy which is something that i care
much about and i thought it would be
good to also have a reference to that as
well so it's also a way to understand i
usually don't go into numerical
symbolism
but it's especially i don't try to talk
about it because
it's difficult to talk about but it can
also show you how
there are ways to represent things in a
manner that
has multiple interpretations but all
those
interpretations are coherent within a
basic symbolic structure so by
differentiating
the basic six circles from the inner one
and then
in the other one also separating the
different elements so that
they could be interpreted as a whole but
also interpreted separately
is a way to uh to kind of hint at those
different
numerical symbols so i think that
i'm pretty much at the end of my
interpretation
hopefully this will be helpful to you uh
to give you some hints there are other
aspects that i didn't talk about i
didn't talk about the snake i didn't
talk about
the relationship of christ to the to the
shape of the snake
there are many things that i haven't
talked about just because
um i don't think you want to listen to a
two-hour video describing
an image but it can give you a sense of
how
powerful the structure of the christian
story is
how powerful the scriptural synthesis
can be
and and why i'm so excited about these
iconographic images and the
possibility of a sacred language of art
and so as i said you know if you're
interested in this image there are ways
to get it just look at the description
you will find links to those
to those different places and uh yeah so
thanks for your attention
on this very kind of um very complicated
subject but in a way it does
point to the basic structure of all my
videos so if you listen to one of my
videos
you can have this image in front of you
and you can think about
you know which aspect of this drawing
that i'm actually talking about
so everybody thanks your time and i will
talk to you very soon
i hope you enjoyed this discussion on
the symbolism of
everything trying to get everything into
one
image as you know everything i'm doing
is thanks to
your support and so if you are
interested in supporting what i'm doing
go check out
the symbolicworld.com support supporters
have access to a monthly free monthly
uh video for supporters only and this
month's video will be
on the story of alexander the great who
built
that wall to stop the barbarians from
coming in
so there's bound to be some interesting
aspects to look at
and to think about so as you know it
always helps if you
enjoy what i'm doing to share this to
subscribe to like to do all the things
that
youtubers ask you to do and so uh once
again i thank you for your support in
these very very strange times
and i will talk to you very soon